[music]
Good afternoon everyone.
Um Helena Chow, managing director, head
of venture capital and crossover
coverage at Bank of America. It's great
to be here with my dear friend Mark
Tierman, CEO and and founder of Dynamic
Creatures. So Mark, you've seen humanoid
robotics go from a curiosity or an idea
to a projected $5 trillion market. And
at Boston Dynamics, you watched the same
scurve just earlier and steeper. So what
did building a commercial organization
from zero um teach you about the gap
between, you know, this works in a lab
um and someone will actually paid for
this?
>> Yeah. So, uh, it's great to see you all.
Thanks for coming. I think the the big
learning at Boston Dynamics was, uh,
that Boston Dynamics always launches
robots very early. Um, and sometimes
maybe a little bit too early, but the
reason that Boston Dynamics does this is
because we think what you need to learn,
uh, you can only learn in a real world
and you can't learn it in a lab. And so,
um, you know, you launch robots early,
you get out there. And what's
interesting about legged robotics in
particular is that the excitement at the
executive level is of course very
strong. So it's actually fairly easy to
sell a robot. It's very very difficult
to sell fleets of robots.
Um and so most people who look at the
market projections and you know they see
dollars but you probably look at it and
you see sales teams, go to market
organizations.
So what does a company need to have
built by 2030 to be credible um in the
robotic space and how many of those
components did you have to grow from
scratch at Boston Dynamics? Yeah. So
when I joined Boston Dynamics about six
years ago, um it was a research
institute and so we we had to build the
entire go to market muscle from scratch
and um you know there's there's obvious
things like the sales team, a marketing
team but I think what we underestimated
dramatically was what it takes to deploy
these robots in the real world and how
large of a team you need because we
noticed early on that when we show up
with a robot, for example, Spot, which
you guys have seen outside, when you
show up with a with a Spot robot at a
logistics company or at a manufacturing
company, if there's nobody there to
catch the ball, um it's very hard and
the implementation will fail. And so in
the initial years, we tried to use
systems integrators and third party
companies that would help us pull these
robots into these companies. Uh but the
systems integrators six years ago
weren't ready for this. Uh nobody had
done uh legged robot deployments and so
we built an integration team uh from
scratch uh under Spencer Brower which
has become one of the larger teams at
Boston Dynamics because we realized that
you really need to hold people's hands
uh and and pull these uh pull these
robots in. And then we noticed okay now
the robots are deployed. Okay, that
worked. Uh then we quickly realized okay
um what happens if they break? Uh surely
the host company isn't ready to repair
these robots. So you need to build a
global repair team
uh in order to prop up the reliability
of of these early uh early deployments.
Uh so we built out a service and support
team. Um and then the last team that we
built out we realized okay if some
somebody needs to own the relationship
with the customer. So the final team
that we built last year was a customer
success team. So somebody that just owns
the relationship
uh and is the is the happy call. Um so
yeah it uh it and so to answer your
question, any robotics company that's uh
that's in the audience or is uh at the
summit today will need to build out all
these functions um because you can't
rely on third parties to do it. And so
it's it's expensive.
>> So there's there's a narrative that
robotics companies have um to choose
between being a platform or being a
product company. Which which one do you
think is more efficient and which one do
you think is quicker to scale?
So in my goto market team together with
our friends in in product we had a
product um we had a book that u became
our bible which is Jeffrey Moore's book
crossing the chasm. It's a 20year-old
book that was written for the software
industry uh and the the early uh
internet boom but if you haven't read it
you should definitely put it on your
list because it's super relevant for
robotics companies. And the central
hypothesis of the book is that um it's
it's easy to sell an initial pilot
deployment, especially if you have a
sexy walking robot. But then um that
pilot deployment was probably sold to an
executive who wants to be at the
forefront of technology,
who wants to use the robot to market
their own uh company. Hey, look how
innovative I am. I'm using walking
robots. But all of a sudden you want to
sell the second robot and the 10th and
then the 100th robot and all of a sudden
you're faced with the operations manager
on the shop floor uh who doesn't care
about the sexiness and the marketing.
The only thing that that person cares
about is return on investment and does
the robot actually provide value in my
daily life and does it make my job
easier. And so Jeffrey's um hypothesis
is that there's a giant chasm between
that early pilot deployment and this
operational adoption deployment and
crossing this chasm is is so difficult
and I think that many of the robotics
companies will face this chasm. That's
why the book is is still so relevant. Um
and so the uh one of the chapters in the
book talks about that it's virtually
impossible to cross the chasm as a
platform company because it's uh it's
too broad. So at Boston Dynamics when we
started selling spot 6 years ago, we
didn't really know what the robot was
going to be used for, right? It was an
innovation looking for a market. And
when we found product market fit in
industrial inspection, it seems obvious
now. It wasn't obvious back then at all,
but we built out the entire product
around this industrial inspection so
that we could cross the chasm with a
complete product. Um, all the while
maintaining the fact that Boston
Dynamics is a platform company. It has
open APIs. Anybody in the audience here
can write an API to talk to Spot, but to
get companies to buy fleets of robots,
we had to complete the product solution.
>> And so, and so when we look at the
market projections, analysts say that in
in 10 years, consumer and service is
going to outweigh industrial and
represent 50% um of the market. This
sounds a lot like the smartphone scurve
that we've seen in the '9s. And when you
were at Boston Dynamics scaling revenue,
did you feel that the you know did you
feel the ground shifting under your feet
in the same way?
So I think it's true when I when I look
at the projections um from the big three
banks and uh and smart companies like
McKenzie, everybody comes to the
conclusion that by 2035 this humanoid
market is going to be a $40 billion
market. I think that's probably true.
Um, and I don't think that's overly
optimistic,
but what's not talked about that much is
that when you look at these projections
and you dig a little bit deeper, that
50% of that $40 billion is not going to
be industrial, but is split between
consumer applications and hospitality
and service applications.
And
so there appears to be a giant
opportunity out there for non-industrial
humanoid applications. Uh we heard our
friends from electronic talk about this
earlier. The reason that that hasn't
happened yet is of course because the
models are not quite ready. The robots
are not quite ready to go out in the
real world and and semantically
understand their environment in such a
way that they can walk around in
unstructured environments and safety is
is not quite figured out. I noticed that
one person was walking around with a
modified um six- foot tall humanoid out
here right in the crowd. I don't know. I
thought that was I probably would have
not done that. Um but I you know yes. So
I I think um the the short answer is I
think there's a tremendous opportunity
in the market that is untapped at the
moment. And um while we see companies
throw out videos of this is my 6' tall
humanoid unloading your dishwasher,
I'm not so sure, right? A the dishwasher
is the automation equipment already. So
really it's machine tending at that
point. And I think if I brought a 6ft
tall humanoid home to my wife and said,
"Hey honey, that's our new helper to
unload the dishwasher."
I think she would not enjoy that.
So I guess without like giving away too
much, how how do how could you see
physical AI stepping into these unmet
needs?
>> I think you need to be invited into the
home, right? Right now we have an entire
industry building what is possible. uh
which is super cool and there's amazing
robotics companies building that but the
they're all building industrial uh
machines and then they put out a YouTube
video and saying and that machine will
also be in the home. I I don't think
that that's going to be the case. So I
think we haven't seen the form factor
yet that will be invited into the home.
>> Any um any any other I guess ideas you
can share in terms of what could make
sense to be invited into the home? I
mean, for example, we would love a
robotic dog. My kids really want a real
dog, but we just, you know, we don't
want to pick up after it. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Well, I I think, you know, you
either don't want to pick after it,
which is one thing, or maybe you're uh
an elderly person living in an apartment
building and you're either too old to
take care uh of a dog or maybe you're
not allowed to have uh a dog in an
apartment building. I do think that
there's a giant loneliness epidemic on
the planet and you have millions of
lonely people sitting in some mega
metropolis city in a high-rise um and
not able um to to have a pet which might
be the better thing and not able to have
human connections. So I think there
there's something there if you scratch
under the surface that that might be
possible. Um I think it it's not quite I
think the technology is not quite there
yet. But um I certainly if you fast
forward 10 years into the future um
everyone in this audience will have a
robot at home. Um and many already do,
right? Many people have vacuum cleaners,
many people have lawnmowers. Um but in
addition to those, I think we will have
robots that that live with us for sure.
So, I mean, um, we'll have time to open
it up to the audience for questions,
too, because Mark is literally a legend
in the robotics world. So, I want to
make sure that you guys all have a
chance to ask questions. Um, is there
anything that we haven't covered yet,
Mark, that that you want to impart to
this audience, just given, you know,
your experience at at Boston Dynamics?
>> And I think there's a lot of talk at the
moment. People always ask me, well,
isn't there so much hype at the moment?
Isn't that dangerous? Um, and I I don't
think so. I mean, look at these amazing
robots that we see here today. And then
when you look at the tremendous
exponential advances in AI that our
friends at DeepMind for example are
pushing forward, you can squint and you
can see that this will be the biggest
generational opportunity uh in our
lifetime in terms of function step
change. Um, what does annoy me is then
when when companies put out videos that
project things that are not quite
possible and are saying that it's
happening tomorrow. Um, so you know with
uh with my ex- friends at Boston
Dynamics, my ex-colagues, my current
friends ex-colagues at Boston Dynamics,
we always struggled with the fact how do
you keep the messaging real in a
somewhat posttruth era, right?
um
you know in in this post-truth era you
can become very powerful uh in terms of
commercial success and political success
but how as a startup do you say what's
really possible and uh take advantage of
the of the tremendous interest and hype
that's out there in the market
>> with with that why don't we open it up
to the audience for a few questions I
think we've got about 5 minutes or So
there
>> no it's fine.
>> Okay. Um, and I get a little bit scared
with physical AI because I have a
feeling that it'll go like social media
and we'll end up with lowest common
denominator products like doom
scrolling, like pornography, like a lot
of the things that are very easy
purchasing of cosmetics products using
social media and then physical layout.
Why won't we also have a race to the
bottom with simple disruptive disruptive
inense?
Um, so I raised two daughters in uh in
the United States who are both of course
addicted to social media and I've seen
the the very dark sides of it. So yes uh
certainly there's a dark side to to
technology always but what I've also
seen is you know over the last six years
I visited probably [snorts] 500
factories and logistics centers and the
the the narrative that I'm getting from
everybody in the industry is like we
cannot find humans anymore that want to
do these types of jobs. That is true in
the service industry. Um in a postcoavid
after co so many people disappeared from
the workforce where they all went is a
little bit unclear but they're not there
anymore. That's very uh true in service
industry but of course it has an
outsized impact in manufacturing
industries. Um, so in car manufacturing,
in logistics centers, you know, people
have 120% turnover year-over-year,
meaning you hire six people on a Friday,
they do the job over the weekend, and
then only a couple of them show up on
Monday because these jobs are literally
backbreaking. And so while um especially
in North America there is a very dark
fictional narrative around these robots,
the reality on the ground seems to be
that they're really needed because uh we
can't find humans uh to do these jobs
anymore. And of course then there's
super obvious use cases like I was in um
in Fukushima a couple of months ago and
stood you know 500 yards from the from
the nuclear reactor. there's no plan of
record how to bring that down, clean it
all up and make it into a meadow again,
right? Um, and robots could could play a
super important role there. So,
the the dancing and back flips uh are
actually important because they bring
the general public along. You know, at
Boston Dynamics, we always uh split our
time between real
use cases and case studies around
specific customer use cases to show the
industry what's currently possible. But
then we did back flips uh on YouTube to
to bring the general public along and
say, look, this is not scary, right?
This is uh this is fun technology. So,
uh it's it's both.
Maybe time for one more question from
the audience.
So um Boston Dynamics has done multif
fleet deployments up to 50 robots in
single facilities where the the robots
work together um
on monitoring everything that's going on
in the plant with superhuman sensors.
Um, truly you can have Mike the intern
walk around with the notepad and a
thermal camera, but Mike the intern
takes the picture. Sometimes
[clears throat] he does, sometimes he
doesn't. He certainly doesn't uh um keep
track of it versus a robot of course
keeps beautiful track of uh of
everything that's going on. Um, but I
think the next speaker that's coming up
actually has an amazing use case where
he has uh fleets of robots that actually
talk to each other to complete a
specific task together. And I think
that's sort of the next generation of uh
multifleet deployments. Um, we already
see that in the drone industry of
course, but I think that type of
technology is now coming to um to leed
robots and field AI is one of the
leaders in that field.
With that, we are out of time. This is a
lot of fun. Thanks, Mark.
>> Thank you so much.